hello and welcome to this video playing
gender here from the Netherlands let's
hope I can keep my good score iam 6 wins
0 losses two draws seven out of eight
that's not bad but should be six sir the
sister named become common knowledge on
all levels that we should be six as a
decent in this particular position and
Bishop C aid back him or Mookie aids
comparable black plays Bishop see a
droopy a net f2 d7 and then he five okay
that's not blacks plan here maybe he
wants to go Bishop to f5 I should have
played maybe Bishop d3 first could have
been maybe more precise hmm no should
have done that okay it's not a big deal
probably hmm
that's also a decent idea cannot take or
any least it isn't net much okay it's
develop oh she bet five is also an
option okayed this one and he wants to
play Bishop of seven and then if five in
in one go hmm that's interesting
yes an e-form
is usually correct antidote but my
pieces are somewhat badly positioned to
do that okay yeah if five I'm going to
play D takes five or if or immediately
I'm not sure and I for immediately
that's probably D 494 f5 which feels
wrong yeah this is not I'm not very
happy with this but not sure that had
anything better I don't think so okay
just all the way back
hmm tough to say yeah I saw the move but
I wasn't sure if it really helps him
that much if I was hanging okay um the
ship c4 I guess opening up for 91-93
[Music]
his bishop is still somewhat problematic
piece yeah just as I said it he probably
had the right idea here g3 is really
risky strategically not trading this not
sure about it okay let's play this it's
probably a more natural move check
yeah how to plan some kind of F for the
right moment would be good like Queen g4
and FF for trying to open up against his
slightly slightly more weakened King who
is it will be three and idea now or what
is he doing then 26 I guess
[Music]
yeah man who conceived or is this kind
of kind of question well I think I'll
just retreated it's very sensitive to
tempie with Queen e-cigs and so on mmm
they simply doesn't want to take the
pawn which I don't understand really I
see flying for tricks a group of seven
creepy seven nights of fire I guess but
I have this move so he will take and
play queen is six I guess huh
okay again if I take it I don't have
anything great about Jake yeah so let's
do it takes group he gets got pretty
sexist is really really still okay for
him I guess cakes Queenie six all the
media 26 yeah I can take and go at five
I'm not sure if this is better or
anything it looks interesting that this
looks like interesting plane the group
moves ng form and here this is
interesting so
he's got two points himself but yeah if
96 also just trying to sharpen up the
play a little bit without being sure
that it is actually actually good
[Music]
yeah well f6 you go where are you taking
us
chicks chicks okay I didn't even see
that I'm playing great Jessie at the
moment it's really brilliant didn't see
anything here Wow I mean things are
maybe not entirely clear but so I mean I
should see the odd move at least d - ok
- eight maybe some so I think I'm still
stopping stop stopping him here
[Music]
is not threatening this because of f7
time warning so still probably best to
but I just don't know how I just don't
know where maybe he actually going to g4
[Music]
check f7 is a pretty substantial threat
and eat trees hanging
so just take III maybe I don't think I
can do it it's probably the safest move
yeah check yet why f7 and rook e8
orbital 7 & 7 you would have to SEC the
exchange yeah let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right still not so easy jeez six
it's not clear that I'm winning this
maybe I have to bring the king over
check black for five times
yeah that was probably the right to
right choice I'm winning the Hawker
inside here mmm
tough game a tough game I didn't I'm not
sure about all this units let's have a
look at the opening phase of the game
then with f6 but I think that that
seemed to be okay for him I would have
liked to play a form myself but I don't
think it works I think he can even take
him as weird as it looks but I think he
can this move there's Queen to a5 or if
I if I mean this looks bad but my pieces
are all loose so now the engine agrees
so I think this is probably best I have
to go back and here you can certainly
argue if I should take or not I mean
computable so play but should be to him
giving equality I don't know why I
didn't like that idea now we are engine
wants to play Queen e7 and gives black a
clear edge interesting
this this this is a five yeah I cannot
play a three him this is the thing I
mean okay technically I can I can't I
have to check check and this is a clash
with like according to the compound
hmm I wouldn't have thought of thought
so
Rocky's got the info and Sam well Jim he
has got the I found this is just the
important thing there are some things
that are not so bad for me like the five
porn can be under fire whatever but they
found them I came and the way it went oh
yeah I could have taken you five which I
did not think about hmm
there was a bad mafia that I just
reacted here I could have taken which is
rather interesting this is this is a
very good compensation for the exchange
but like f4 this is a monster Bishop
well I was really bad miss Kay I went
there and now he had this Jenny okay
this is probably about equal right Jenny
its kind of think we need six yeah I
know I was yeah trying to complicate
matters that might be objectively wrong
my Angela thinks black is better here
oops
there with precisely the line that we
had I mean it's still kind of kind of
tricky but his two pawns he should win
here but he made some mistakes this is a
mistake should play III and keep his
material hmm now after this there is
before and now it's rather black who's
in trouble and yeah I'm better check and
step by step he had no time or less time
than I had and step by step it got a
winning position and was lucky really
lucky okay thanks for watching